[موسيقى]
وجه الغرب ويقولون لبوتين سمعا وطاعه وهل
للاصابع الجزائريه اثر على خد دلوعه
اوروبا نعم نحن نتحدث عن فرنسا وطردها من
النيجر لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله واكثر
تابع الفيديو للنهايه
الصاعقه ايام قليله مضت على اول انقلاب
عسكري في النيجر والذي نزل على راس الغرب
والفرنسيين خصوصا كالصاعقه في لحظات قليله
سلب من فرنسا اخر معاقلها في غرب افريقيا
لقد كانت تحتوي على بحر من اليورانيوم
وغيرها من الثروات التي عامت فيه باريس
لاعوام طويله شعب النيجر يكشر عن انيابه
صوب احفاد لواس ويضربون النيران في سفاره
فرنسا بالعاصمه نيامي ويكررون رفع العلم
الروسي وكانهم يعلنون فوز الدب الروسي على
ضباع الغرب دون حتى ان يتحرك من مكانه
باريس ترتعد يرسل الطائره الفرنسيه من اجل
انقاذ الرعي الفرنسيه في النيجر واجلائهم
من البلاد وقبل ان تغادر اخر طائره فرنسيه
ليصيح الديكو الفرنسي قائلا المعركه لم
تنتهي بعد لن استسلم وساعود قريبا وكل شيء
سيعود كما كان فلماذا قالها الفرنسيون
وكيف ردت عليهم اسود افريقيا
انتهى الامر لا يزال الغرب تحت تاثير
الصدمه خصوصا احفاد لوس الذين لا يصدقون
حتى الان ما حدث وكانه مشهد من برنامج
الصدمه لقد ذهبت النيجر من ايديهم وفي
ساعات قليله ودون اي مقدمات الخسائر اكبر
من ان يتحملها ماكرون باريس و واشنطن تدفع
لمجموعه اكواس الافريقيه لفرض عقوبه
اقتصاديه قاسيه على النيجر المجلس العسكري
النيجيري يفضح اتفاقا خفيا بين مكروه
واعوان بازم من اجل تدخل فرنسا عسكريا
بالنيجر فقد الجنرال امد عبد الرحمن تامرت
فرنسا على النيجر فقد عقدت اتفاقا مع بعض
النيجيريين وهيئه اركان الحرس الوطني يخول
لها التدخل العسكري في النيجر دون اي
مسائله من المجتمع الدولي ماكروي اريد
العوده حتى وان كانت بالقوه العسكريه
ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي
يعلنها صراحه ملتزمون باعاده محمد على راس
السلطه فنيجر لياتي الرد سريعا فقد اعلنت
مالي وبوركينا فاسو في بيان مشترك ردا على
تهديدات الغرب نعلن رفضنا تطبيق العقوبات
غير القانونيه وغير الانسانيه ضد النيجر
وشعبها ونحذركم من اي تدخل عسكري في
النيجر لانه سيكون بمثابه اعلان حرب ليس
على النيجر فقط بل على مالي وبوركينا فاسو
ايضا لتلتحق بهم غينيا وتزيد الطين بله
على الغرب وتعلن رسميا نرفض عقوبه ايكو اس
على النيجر
بها واي تدخل عسكري في النيجر سيؤدي الى
تفكك المنظمه كلها ولكن لماذا اختارت
افريقيا بوتين بديلا عن فرنسا فهناك
ايطاليا العدو اللدود لفرنسا من الجنه الى
الجحيم يرى الافارقه ان الدب الروسي يزيد
من طعامهم بينما الديك الفرنسي يبتلع
لقمتهم بشراهه فلم يكتفي بوتين بطرد
الفرنسيين من غرب افريقيا واحكام قبضته
عليها من خلال قوه فاغنر بل اجهز الدب
الروسي على ضحيته واعلن في مؤتمر القمه
الروسيه الافريقيه انه سيمد حلفائه من
افريقيا بالقمح مجانا وزاد عليها انشاء
محطه نوويه وانه فقط مجرد شريك وبالحصه
المناسبه والتي ترضى بها افريقيا وكانه
يقول ضعي الخير يعم الجميع الصاعقه تضرب
رؤوس احفاد لواس فمن لم ينضم
سيسارع بالانضمام بعد هذا القرار بحور
الثروات الطبيعيه ستصبح في قبضه الدب
الروسي وحلفاءه واصبح لسان حالي ماكرون
يقول وتحولت جنتنا الى جحيم لا يطاق لياتي
الرد من مكان مجهول مهلا يا مكروه
فالصفعات لم تاتي بعد فهناك عملاق اخر
يريد تصفيه حساباته معك اظنك قد عرفت من
هواه انه الجزائر ولكن ما علاقه الجزائر
بتلك المجزره الاقتصاديه والعسكريه وما
تعانيه فرنسا في افريقيا وما سر سقوط
الدول الافريقيه من يد فرنسا بتلك السرعه
اقترب يوم العزاء
عقود طويله لم تكن كافيه لينسى الجزائريون
فارهم عند الفرنسيين قالها الزعيم هواري
بومدين جهارا للرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق
اذا وضعت قدميك في افريقيا فساقطعها لك لا
تتعجب يا عزيزي من وجود بصمات الجزائر في
هذا الصراع الدولي ولا ننسى زياره الرئيس
الجزائري الاخيره لروسيا فبعد تلك الزياره
لم ترى فرنسا الخير بعدها وكانهم يقولون
حان وقت الانتقام من احفاظ اللواس واقترب
يوم العزاء في شهدائنا فقد ضمت الجزائر
صوتها الى الاصوات التي ترفض التدخل
العسكري الفرنسيه في النيجر واضف عليها ان
النيجر فتحت حدودها البريه والجويه في وجه
الجزائر كاول دوله تدخلها بعد اعلان
الانقلاب مباشره ولملاء فالدولتان اجتمعتا
على عدو واحد وحليف واحد ونقصد روسيا ولكن
برغم ذلك يبدو ان هناك شيء ما يخطط له من
تحت الطاوله
ما يظهر في السياسه للعالم اقل بكثير مما
يحدث في الخفاء هكذا يقول التاريخ فبرغم
ازمه النيجر المتفجره هناك انباء غير
مؤكده عن مفاوضات تحدث من تحت الطاوله بين
الاستخبارات الروسيه والفرنسيه من اجل
ايقاف فرنسا عن دعم اوكرانيا ضد روسيا في
مقابل ان تترك روسيا النيجر ولكن هل هذا
ممكن المنطق يقول لا وحتى ان واشنطن
باوستا نشرت ذلك التسريب فلن ينسى بوتين
ما خسره في اوكرانيا ليوافق على الصفقه
الفرنسيه وبعيدا عن اي شيء يا عزيزي هل ما
حدث في النيجر وما قبلها في بوركينا فاسو
ومالي يعد انقلابا عسكريا ام هو عمليه
تبديل محتل ونقصد التخلص من ثوب الاحتلال
الفرنسي ليلبس ثوب الاحتلال الروسي
انقلاب ام تحرير
دعني اقول لك اننا اذا تحدثنا بلغه
الاعراف الدوليه فما حدث في تلك البلاد
الافريقيه هو انقلاب عسكري ولكن قد يكون
للحقيقه زاويه اخرى غير مرئيه فالبعض يرون
ان هذه الانقلابات تعد تحريرا للبلاد من
استعمار فرنسا الخفي لها ووجود حلفائها
على راس السلطه ليحولونها الى مرتع
للفرنسيين ينهبون ثروات ويضيئون بلادهم
بكنوزها الثمينه في الوقت الذي يعاني فيه
اصحاب تلك البلدان انفسهم من المشي حفاه
القدمين والجوع الذي نهب منهم لذه الحياه
نفسها لنقولها باختصار هم من افقر شعوب
العالم ويمشون على الذهب السؤال لكم
مشاهدينا هل ستعود فرنسا الى النيجر مره
اخرى بالقوه ام ان الدب الروسيه سيتدخل
ننتظر منكم التعليقات
[موسيقى]